oh
yeah okay all right y'all what's up
welcome to griffin with
okay well that's the theme song as you
can see i am like someplace completely
different this week
i'm actually in florida i'm in west palm
beach florida at the improv
i was at the improv all weekend so i'll
tell you about that but once again
thanks for being here
we're from with griffin it's like a job
for me
sometimes because look i have to do it
even when i'm not
um you know at home in the roofing with
griffin studios
so i'm here no wiggy this week even
though he's probably going to help me
edit
but you know he's not here with me
because i'm in west palm beach florida
um you know and you know i still have
been trying to game check out riffing
with griffin oh i got a 16
16 kill my personal best on warzone
so you can see that video on error
griffin gaming
so make sure you check that out so i had
uh
five shows this weekend two on friday
two on saturday one on sunday
and it was great you know this is only
my second time being out on the road
um and this was like a fallout weekend
too like it was like three weeks ago i
found
that they they hey they had the person
who was supposed to be here had to
cancel so then they hit me up like hey
can you do this show and hit my agent
major say oh and you wanna do this show
it's in like three weeks
so and i'm here um you know and it's
just i guess i just basically just wanna
talk about doing comedy and
excuse me doing comedy post you know
while the pandemic is running
you know winding down and you know what
it's like to
you know be here what it's like to do
comedy right now
it's like you know you hear a lot of
comics always talking about cancer
culture and wokeness and all this kind
of stuff
and i guess i've talked about this
before but
i don't necessarily have the same kind
of feeling about it as i did before
because it's more nuanced
you know it's so easy just to be like
you know
you know it's so easy just to be like yo
everybody's too sensitive and all that
kind of stuff
and you know so i'm gonna go into that
and some things and just some
just some general stuff that has been
going on you know this weekend
actually we start with this uh this is
strange thing
because this goes into my comedy kind of
things that i like to talk about in my
comedy but i'm gonna tell you something
that happens so i stream
i stream on twitch i do it most most
days
uh eric twitch dot tv slash eric griffin
gaming i usually use twitch so
you know and these people a lot of the
the people they're great people actually
you know
i talk [ __ ] i call them pieces of [ __ ]
because sometimes they're just too much
you know because
you know people like to troll people
like and then they're demanding and they
just you know so it's like
i jokingly call them pieces of [ __ ] so
and i know that a lot of them watch my
podcast so i'm talking to you guys
specifically and shout out to a couple
of guys that actually came to the show
in west palm beach a couple of the uh
regulars that follow me they actually
came to the show so it's interesting to
see these people that you see their name
all the time on the screen
actually come to the show so that was
great you know it made me feel like
people
are actually paying attention to me and
i feel loved you know
so thanks shout out to those guys that
came to the show um but
so this is something that happened in in
online on streaming i just wanted to
talk about it because it really kind of
like it just
it's such a such a strange thing about
human behavior so
a lot of people chat so there's a lot of
chatting going on while i'm streaming a
lot of junk talk going on you know a lot
of smack talk a lot of trolling
a lot of people asking about bobby just
to be trolls a lot of like you know this
all this kind of stuff that goes on you
know in the thing so
one this one guy he comes into the chat
and he's and by the way i'll give you a
timeout i talk smack right back at you
i'm not like regular streamers
you know a lot of these streamers are
introverted or they don't or they care
about like oh hey thank you for being
here oh my god thank you so much you
know i'm not like that you know i'm
appreciative of other people especially
my subscribers who pay their hard earned
money or
they use their prime accounts thank you
very much you've helped me greatly
during during this pandemic and
you know i hope the content i'm giving
you you appreciate it so there's a lot
you know but there's a lot of
entitlement that comes with that you
know what i mean people think like hey i
pay
five dollars a month so that means you
have to do whatever i say it's that kind
of like [ __ ] feeling that people
have but
it is what it is and they know me we
have a rapport
so there's a thing called giving people
a time out which means if i give them a
timeout
any number any um you know amount i want
time amount i want like 10 seconds a
minute
10 minute timeout 30 minute timeout it
just means that they can watch the
stream but they can't chat anymore
and i'm you know and i don't do it
easily you know i and i don't ban people
just like just because i they don't
i don't like them i don't do that either
it takes a lot to get banned from my
channel you
you're being a real [ __ ] then you're
out
all right so some guy comes on
and he starts chatting and he's
he's saying weird stuff okay i got
i don't even he's just saying weird
stuff it's just it seems trolly but we
don't know
and then sprinkled in with the weird
things he's saying
is some rude comments so
he's being rude but he's being weird we
don't know what's going on
and i let it go for a long time then it
just got to a point where i was like all
right this guy needs a timeout
20 30 40 minutes in you know after a lot
of like
whatever the hell he was saying time out
for him
then we get a mess then one of my mods
moderator of the channel so so they
there's like i have like four or five
people that are like moderators so they
look at this stuff and they could be
like all right that guy's got a timeout
i got to get rid of this guy
we could leave each other mod notes it's
actually a pretty cool community if you
know
these are like fans that have become
like a part of the channel
so one of the mods tells me hey man i
got a message from
this guy that you gave a timeout to he's
so upset and it's like okay bye see ya
you know what i mean
all right so then i get a message from
the guy and he says this
he goes hey i have asperger's
so you shouldn't be too quick to give
somebody a time out
blah blah blah goes on and on and on
with this like entitlement excuse
that people like to people like to use
their ailments
people like to use tragedies in their
life
as an excuse for
bad behavior as an excuse for like
special treatment
nah man sorry it don't work like that on
eric griffin gaming
and i'm gonna tell you why if you have
an ailment if you are autistic
because this is on the spectrum of that
if you're autistic and you have
trouble communicating with people all
right
and you can you start communicating with
them for an extended period of time and
they don't get you
it's time for you to step up and say yo
guys i know it seems like i'm being
weird but
i i have asperger's that's what's going
on right now
now i'm not saying you have to do that
up top i'm saying
once you see people aren't getting you
the message is getting lost in the
delivery
that is on you to be like yo hey guys
and then we can make the decision like
oh now we get it
all good dude or if you're being a
[ __ ] you could be like i don't care
see you later right
whatever whatever the thing might be but
for me i hate when people do this kind
of stuff
like i'm holding you accountable bro
you were being an [ __ ] you were being
the ass
in asperger's okay and i'm sorry
you don't get to use that later you
don't get to use that
to let yourself off the hook later
because people responded to you in a way
that is like perfectly acceptable for
the way
you were acting you can't come later and
be like well
i was acting this way because of this if
you can use that as an excuse
then you can use it sooner
like i just i can't stand it you know it
would be like
if you got a nut allergy right and you
go to somebody's house
you know they serving you food and it's
just nuts all over the food it's just
nuts that's nothing that's nuts okay
nuts in the salad you know it's like a
nut crusted rib eye or whatever you know
and then this is how you respond you
you're you're you're going like oh
i can't eat this what's this yeah what
man i just why would you i can't eat
that i don't like this
i just you just had a general attitude
like ugh
and then the person goes well shut up
well you know i'm serving you this food
and then they get mad and kick you out
you can't come back later and be like
hey
i have a nut allergy so you know
you're a little rude to kick me out
because i have a nut allergy
like now [ __ ] you know what you're
supposed to do up top you go
hey thanks for cooking dinner just i
have a nut allergy so i can't eat this
and then problem solved they go oh i
wish you would have said something or
whatever the thing's gonna be after that
but you can't come after the fact people
responding to your shitty ass
behavior and then you come with your
excuse like we're supposed to just let
you off the hook
don't work like that man sorry bruh
so to the autistic community out there
and the people that like you know
you know what just teaches you is that
not even just it ain't even about the
autistic community it's about
human beings in general anybody no
matter where you come from
no matter what's up with you i don't
care if you're handicapped i don't care
if you're autistic i don't care if
you're
you know you got a limp i don't care if
you got whatever your thing is that you
got you could still be an [ __ ]
and people can respond to you as such
regardless of your thing you don't get
to use that as a shield
all the time you know so learn
that and that goes for anybody listening
to my podcast out there this is just a
lesson in like hey
you know we should listen it's not like
we were treating this guy like [ __ ] up
top you know
it was like it just was weird because we
didn't know what was going on what he
was saying
that he wants to come back later and be
like well i was being weird because i'm
weird and then what are we supposed to
say to that you know
okay as you can see like stuff comes on
the screen there
that's my phone notifications are coming
up on the screen because you guys don't
even know what i had to do to do this
podcast
this is my iphone right here okay i got
it hooked up to my computer
with obs and then i have my my mic
hooked up to this mixer
i didn't bring the right stuff you know
so it's just a whole thing but
but i just i feel responsible and and i
i have to do my podcast you know what i
mean it's just i've made it a thing that
i do every week
i have ads i have sponsors i i have you
know my
my small but strong community of fans
and i do this for you so i'm doing it
right now so occasionally some stuff
might pop up on the screen it is what it
is
[Laughter]
so yeah that's that so that's something
that happened like during this trip
while i was gaming
you know so i guess getting back to what
i was talking about with um
you know that you know the sensitivity
issue and i've talked about this before
but it's like you know we're all
sensitive man
like i'm not mad at you if you sensitive
you know what i mean but sensitivity
or being um you know uh outraged over
things or
you know feeling offended okay
like all all that kind of stuff is also
based on circumstances
you know uh context is important
you know meaning like there's a time and
place for certain things
and that context is what makes people
really feel offended you know if you're
in the workplace and then some
you know person is uh
some if you're a woman in the workplace
and then just out of nowhere some guy is
like
inappropriately flirting with you or
whatever that whatever that kind of
behavior
you're offended for a lot of reasons one
the main thing is like
this is an inappropriate this isn't the
time
or place for you to make you know
advances
on me it's not supposed to be done at
work so that context of that is
important like you're right
you know the location of where you are
it determines like
why you would feel a certain way about
that that is a part of it
you know if you're in the middle of a
meeting and then somebody decides in the
middle of this meeting to start talking
about you know well let me
you know palestine and israel
this ain't the setting for this
discussion
which is why somebody might be offended
you know
that context is important
so i guess as a comic we're starting we
we're just trying to say
at the comedy club this is the place
for whatever this is that we're talking
about and i don't have
ill intent i say this now before i do
shows now i say it up top of my shows i
go listen guys
i don't have ill intent in my heart
there's going to be punch lines there's
going to be butts of the joke there's
going to be
you know there's going to be we're going
to make fun of this the kind of people
that kind of people
but it's not for ill intent this is
we're at a comedy show
so even if you don't like it it's okay
it's okay for you not to like it but it
doesn't mean
at that like try not to judge after that
not
you know you don't like a joke that
someone says you don't like a point
someone's trying to make in a comedy act
now you take that and be like well this
person is this well that means he's a
racist or he hates women or he hates
you know this and that no no no it was
like
it's not that it's not it doesn't
need to go that far because the context
of where we are
the environment is for jokes
what's been happening right now with
cancer culture and awokeness
and all this [ __ ] that people think
is that they're offended
first it's like when when you're if
you're
searching through someone's twitter and
you're going back years on someone's
twitter
to look for something that means you're
already offended
and you need to find something to
justify it that kind of behavior to me
is just ridiculous it loses
its bite it loses the substance of what
for people that are actually offended in
a moment and it takes away the
opportunity to be like hey can we
discuss this
hey you said this and i didn't like that
uh now you can go in with
with context i was watching bill maher's
show and he said something really great
you know he was talking a lot about the
israel israel
and the palestine stuff and i'm not
going to get into that because i'm not
versed on it i don't know
a lot about what's going on i just know
that there's a war going on between
these people it's about land and
you know it's about you know you know
the politics of it i'm not going to get
into and i just
i hope it's resolved you know but he
said something so interesting the first
thing he said was like you can't learn
history on instagram
and and straight up you can't learn
history and stuff from
comedians from it's
on comedians that are like like they
don't know
what they're talking about you know what
i mean like i i don't know i'm just
telling you my thoughts you know so
and i think that's something that is
lost in even when
somebody is trying to act like they're
offended by something a comedian says or
does the
the joke of even if you're looking back
on somebody's twitter and you see
something that
you would deem inappropriate i mean
there is a part that's like well how
long ago was this is the person changed
have they grown
even if it's something terrible you're
just like well what was the context of
this are they trying to be funny and
they just missed the mark
or you know it's like at a certain point
we have to go like hey
hey let's discuss this if it's so bad
like like what's your intent is my point
what is your intent if you're trying to
like look back on someone's life what's
your intent is your intent just to be
like
to get like clout clout points uh you
you want your woke points look what i
found and i am ready to like you know
look what i'm doing i'm a champion
so then it's not even about the subject
so like you see something
that you deem racist but you've made it
all about you
finding it you've made it all about like
well we're going to like uh
you know we're going to you know hey
look we're going to cancel this person
look what this and then it becomes about
you not about this overall message of
like stopping hate and not you know the
message gets lost
half the time when people are like
looking to be offended
so i just think that like in the
like i don't get why i don't it just
baffles my mind that like you have
critics and all these things that like
us com like for instance for instance
say a comedy special comes out
and they want to pick it apart in a way
that is so like anti-comedy
like it's one thing to say hey i didn't
find this
funny um
but even though you look at the special
and everyone's laughing you see a whole
crowd of people laughing
so they obviously get the context and
what is happening in this moment
you're at home looking at it and you're
just like yeah
that was terrible it's like okay that's
just your opinion
you know
to try to to try to like enforce your
opinion
and make it like fact to judge the
performer's character
based off your whatever you think it is
i mean it's just like even going down
this road even talking about it even the
way i'm talking about it it's just so
far removed from the the the
the feel of what comedy is supposed to
be about you know
laughter and good will and um
even when you say something really
terrible in the context of it you're
saying it because
you know you think that oh this is a
funny situation
what's up guys uh i want to talk about
my great sponsor of the of the show
better help that's better help better
help
uh you know therapy is like great i've
been to therapy i highly recommend
therapy
uh you know and it's just it really
doesn't like you're not gonna solve your
problems
per se but you will help it helps you
organize your thoughts helps you
pinpoint maybe the causes the roots
the patterns and you're talking with an
actual professional that recognizes
these things that's what therapy is
really about i know there's a stigma on
it but i'm telling you i highly
recommend it
for anyone for any level of whatever is
going on in your head you know
therapy will really like center you and
help you
focus if you find the right thing and
better help helps you find the right
thing better help
assesses your needs and matches you to
your own licensed professional therapist
you contact them in a safe private
online environment you don't got to go
to the
the doctor's office anymore and feel
weird you know because you're in you're
sitting in there and you're wondering
like
you know people are looking at you or
you know you're crossing people
in in the hallways so you know this this
helps it better
look there's a lot of things that people
are dealing with still
even with the pandemic winding down you
know people are still dealing with
depression and stress and anxiety and
how our life is different from what just
happened for this past year so i get it
there's a lot of things lgbt matters
self-esteem trauma
if you have trouble sleeping all of this
stuff
the services available for clients
worldwide all right and
and and better help us committed to
facilitating facilitating great
therapeutic matches this isn't self-help
this is licensed professional therapy
anything you share is confidential
it's convenient it's professional and
most importantly it's
affordable so i want you to start living
a happier
life today and as a listener you'll get
10 percent off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com griffin that's
betterhelp.com.betterhelp.com
griffin come on guys join over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health
and that's betterhelp.com griffin for 10
off
your first month i highly recommend it
hey guys uh let's talk about credit
karma i use credit karma it really helps
you like figure out
let you know where your credit score is
now you know it's important it's
convenient
lets you know what credit cards you're
going to be uh you know
you you know you could get what you can
qualify for keeps you keeps you really
organized i've been using credit karma
even before i got them as a sponsor so
now they are a sponsor so right now
visit creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for a free start
winning
instant karma because who doesn't want
instant gratification
if you're looking for satisfaction
there's no need to wait
with credit karma money you could win
cash reimbursements for
debit purchases credit karma money
is a brand new checking account where
you can win cash reimbursements from
making purchases
this is a new thing and i just got got
into that too so
you know check out credit karma they got
more more going on than just
you know keeping track of your credit
score credit karma money has already
given away
over three million dollars in instant
karma to over 50 000 credit
karma members and counting right now
visit creditkarma.com win money to open
your free account and start winning
instant karma all right let's say it
again go to creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for a free and
start winning
instant karma that's creditkarma.com
win money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma
no purchase necessary exclusion and
exclusions and terms apply c rules
banking services provided by mvp bank
inc
member fdic maximum balance and transfer
limits apply let's get back to the show
so i haven't talked about this yet and i
think it's time i talk about it now like
this thing that happened with my buddy
but tony hinchcliffe you know he's in
austin texas and you know uh
asian comedian goes on before him and
then tony goes up and he like says some
like
you know asian jokes and then the way it
was presented to the
the way it was presented to us on social
media it was if
tony didn't even know who this guy was
that he was some random stranger
asian comic and then tony just out of
the blue decides to go on a racial
tirade against this guy
that's the way they presented it that's
not how it happened
that's not how it happened in the
context of how it happened
tony was making a joke it didn't hit the
mark okay that's all
all right but i get the joke he was
trying to make
you know sometimes in comedy the worst
thing that's going on
you make fun of that for that joke for
the
for the reason that we're making fun of
this because we're not supposed to make
fun of it and that's why it's funny i
mean it's so
meta man it's just it's nuanced you know
but the way they people attacked him i
think it was completely unfair
because they didn't show the whole they
didn't show the whole thing
it's like it's like a lot of levels to
it a lot of level look
there are conversations you probably
have with your friends even in your text
messages that you wouldn't want to be
released
because you say things amongst your
friends that you wouldn't say
to anyone else but once it gets released
you have to answer for it
okay that's the same with this like this
shouldn't have been
recorded and it shouldn't have been
released but once it was released now
it's on tony to answer
whatever that what it was released how
it was released he has to go well you
know
look i'm sorry you guys feel this way
about what i was but this is what i was
trying to do but i'm sorry if you're
offended and
i didn't mean to offend whatever he's
gonna say he has to do that but at the
same time
this was some clout chasing [ __ ] in
my opinion
to put that out with the tone of what's
going on in the country with with cancer
culture and
and then especially with like the the
rise
about asian hate that that whole
movement that's going right there
like that what i'm trying to say is i
understand
the the nature of the joke it's because
of that that
in this joking environment the context
is
that's why that's why it would be funny
you know that's why it would be funny
if it didn't hit the mark i get that you
know hey we can shame him for that hell
yo bro it wasn't funny
okay you didn't you didn't perform it
well enough but to
to attack the guy as if he's some sort
of like he he
like like like he hates asian that's not
that's not the case
and i didn't appreciate how was
presented i i
i just think that it was unfair it was
an unfair characterization
of the guy and it was put out in a way
that it was like it was
weaponized for clout and i just
i didn't like it i didn't like it i'm
not excusing
and i've you know what i've already
explained myself i don't need to like
i hate the fact that you have to like
really posture because people will parse
your words and they'll make it whatever
they want
okay you know and i just i and i take
offense to a bunch of comics who are
like
we're coming out like this isn't comedy
as if like
you know their vanilla comedy is like
what how the only way you could do
comedy
there's lots of different ways to do
comedy there's shock come comedians
there's people that like
try to go for it you know and they just
sometimes you miss the mark but
let's not act like this guy's the
freaking devil so you know i like my
support goes out to tony and my support
goes out to the
the asian comic too like you know you
know it's sometimes
in that environment of like kill tony
the roast battle environment
this kind of roasting you know you're
always getting roasted and you're always
like
i've been on tone on kill tony and tony
goes he just it's too much
for me i don't like it all the time i
don't like well you have to talk [ __ ]
about me every single time i'm sitting
here every single person comes up but
that's the nature of that show
and that guy knows it because he's been
on that show and if you didn't like it
if you didn't like it you go to the dude
because you know him and be like yo man
can you not do this i don't really want
to do this anymore
i don't want to be i don't like the
asian jokes anymore
you know can we move on from it that's
how you handle that
to me that's how you handle that
all right i don't know what people are
going to think of that but you you i'm
sure you'll make it you'll make of it
what you want to make of it but
i said what i had to say that's that
um i just hope we can like i just hope
we can get to a point now where we can
like when
we could just communicate that's really
the thing
you know something goes wrong or you
feel like there's a problem
can we get back to the point where we
though these people can discuss it
can we get to the point where you know
like does everything have to be on the
internet
does everything have to be like put out
there and
now it's just judged and then people
have their own opinions on it when they
don't even know the full story we don't
know the full story we weren't even
there in the room we didn't like comedy
is about being in the room and
experiencing whatever that is it's
really hard to capture that that's why
there's not a lot of great comedy
specials it's hard to make a great
comedy special because
that thing that is happening live in a
room
and you know that's unedited it's
unfiltered and you get a sense of what's
going on
you know there's like a nuance to it
guys there is
and like i say just to say it again i
unders i can
understand the the swing tony was making
to try and make it funny
in that moment you know and
whether he hit the mark or not it's fine
it's neither here nor there
but i'd say one thing let's not judge
the guy like he's some terrible person
because he's not
okay all right boom
um let me see how much time i've been
going this is like
damn i gotta look you know all right i
got my obs over there you know man this
is like i'm over here
jimmy rigging this man i got to i got my
laptop
and then you know with apple they got
these stupid usb cord like
now you i have to have these little
cords sticking out i got so much
equipment when i go on the road with me
you know
not to mention my uh my carrying case
from my xbox i got
my little uh focusrite mixer
which you can't hook up to the iphone i
found out because because it draws too
much power so i needed to bring this
other thing and i didn't bring my
my uh uh anyway it's always something
but i did it i'm here i'm doing it i'm
doing it i'm doing i'm doing it
but the shows were good this weekend i
actually really
i enjoyed this um
this crowd these crowds uh they were
very diverse it was a very diverse crowd
you know a lot of white people was
florida
but it was very diverse and then they
were very much like
i didn't get a sense of like you know
wokeness that wasn't anybody clapping
with their
you know clicking their fingers like oh
look although i i'm so smart what a
that joke i get you know it wasn't
really uh
it wasn't really like that you know yeah
somebody's at my front door you see that
the little
notification came up
i should have turned off notifications
but it's too late already i'm already
going
um yeah but the shows were good and i i
really got a sense that
like i felt like there were there were
some older people there i got a sense of
there was some conservative people there
but
actually conservative people are
actually great comedy audiences now
i actually prefer people that are just
kind of like ah let's go for it
uh you know they're not you know this
this whole kind of woke
culture this this small fringe of the
left wing that is like
you know that we have to like cancel
people and all this kind of stuff it's
not it's not
it's not all progressive it's not all
liberals you know it's a small portion
but they're loud and boisterous and
they're
you know they're they're attacking
comedy and this these crowds this
weekend in florida
shout out to west palm beach florida
they got they they were great
uh it was it was great crowds uh leah
lamarr
she was the uh opener the feature and
she
was you know she's big on clubhouse and
she's like
funny she was very funny she's very
professional very funny and uh you know
so make sure you guys check her out too
all right uh let me um it's not to be a
long episode this week because again i'm
here
you know trying to make this happen
but i do want to say that something i
did
check out while i was out here is uh
this new movie
cruella cruella cruella
rachel really wanted to watch it i have
disney plus
so we paid the 29 and because i'm here
in you know hotel i was like let me
check this out
and i'm gonna do a review of this movie
right now and i gotta tell you
i mean honestly it was fantastic like
emma stone
like this was some oscar [ __ ] i mean
honestly
she was she was
great in this movie so if you don't know
what the movie is about
it reminds me of wicked the play wicked
um
and i think they made a movie i'm not
even sure but wicked is about the wicked
witch
in the wizard of oz it's like her origin
story
it like humanizes the villain so you can
find out this is why this person became
evil
so cruella is about cruella de vil from
the 101 dalmatians
and this is like her origin story this
is like why did she become this evil
woman
and this is and you're seeing this story
and it's like it's so
interesting because these kind of
stories really make you think because
you go we know this is the villain
you know so it's like are we supposed to
like the villain
are we supposed to is a villain should
be humanized and it you know
so it's like this weird kind of
psychological emotions you feel which i
really like
but it was i'm telling you it was really
great it was a great origin story of a
villain
and it was just stylistic and
the music was great it was a lot of
great 70s
music uh the cinematography was
fantastic
the the oh man the costumes and the and
the set
uh the set decorations and and just the
performances
even from the little kids when they were
like because she's telling her story
from
as a kid on and there was this little
black kid
um in in the movie in the beginning part
and he he was so good his performance
was so subtle
and and great uh and the girl playing
the and playing young cruella too she
was great they were all great i'm just
telling you the whole cast
the cast was great um
who's the the main oh man i don't i
can't now i can't look at my phone to
look stuff up but
whoever the other the other lady in it
uh that played the villain of the
villain of villains
it's another oh emma thompson emma yeah
emma thompson emma watson no not emma
watch emma thompson
the older one emma she was great
so the movie was a little devil wears
prada meets wicked
like i it's a way to do it so you know
so it's about cruella
you know she uh as a young girl and you
find out
what happens to her in her life while
she and she ends up in a life of crime
and then you find out
why she and she but she wants to do
fashion and it's just like
and it's all this great fashion and it's
just oh man i
i don't even know if i'm doing it
justice what i'm saying but
you know i'm a big softy i'm a big
sensitive guy so i like all kinds of
things like i loved gilmore girls you
know what i mean
uh when you look when it first came out
i like i like all types of movies i love
avengers i love everything but this
just as a performer as an actor myself
i'm telling you
this was a great movie
i really highly recommend when if you
can go watch cruella
go watch it you know it's not what you
think you know
i i don't know if they even marketed it
properly but it's
dark it's dark it's
you know uh that the performances are
grounded and you feel things
you know and i'm just saying i don't
know if emma stone has ever been better
like just like i'm i'm telling you right
now
i am not gonna be shocked if this chick
gets nominated for an oscar because of
this movie
definitely a golden globe if they if the
golden globes even come back
but it was just really fantastic
and i think you guys i think you guys
should watch it
i really think you guys should watch it
so that's my
review of cruella with emma thompson and
emma
emma thompson emma stone yeah emma
thompson it is emma thompson
right i don't know if i'm not you guys
are telling me in the in the comments
right now you're probably going off on
me so
i do highly recommend you check that out
it was really
really good and then you know just
i know that some people last week they
were complaining about like i talked
about basketball for way too long last
week but i'm a [ __ ] i'm a basketball
fan man
my clippers so my clippers came back
they're in it there's a game going on
right now as i'm recording this podcast
so i hope
i don't know if they did or not i i
almost want to go over and check but
the clippers you know hopefully they're
winning this game right now so hopefully
they did you know as we're
as i'm filming that's going on uh so
that
they hope they tied that series up
anthony glass davis got hurt in the
lakers series so he's like
out for right now who knows if he's
gonna come back if he doesn't that's it
for the lakers there's no way the lakers
can
advance and even think about winning the
championship without both lebron james
and anthony davis so
we'll see what's going on with that
boston beat the nets and i think that
that was the worst things that can
happen
happen for the league because i think
that woke the nets up i think that let
the nets know
yo you're not invincible you really got
to play hard all the time
and then they came in game three it was
a game three
yeah they came in game four and beat
boston
down beat the ass so
we'll see what's going on in that series
he knows it only once in milwaukee man
milwaukee did it they swept the heat and
i really thought that he'd had a chance
if you guys have been listening you know
i talked about dr heath they went to the
championship last year
and you know they beat they had beaten
milwaukee but milwaukee came out like
they they're the ones man i think in
that so that series nets milwaukee
that is gonna be a fantastic series
because the sixers
they're gonna cruise into the uh eastern
finals there's no way that atlanta who's
about to beat the knicks
can beat the sixers just so just look
for the sixers verse
the winner of the milwaukee and the net
series and that's gonna be
really really good
well all right guys um you know i don't
know i don't even know what else to say
uh you know that's probably gonna be
like let me see where we're at right now
this is probably going to be like a
really short episode but you know it
doesn't matter i don't have to have a
big old long episode every single time
right maybe some of you guys probably
liked a little short episode i mean it
is what it is
um but uh next week i will be
in austin texas uh my this new movie a
movie i was in which i'll probably do a
review of on my podcast hero mode
is coming out so that's gonna be in
austin next week um
you know actually like friday i believe
it's either friday or saturday i think
if you're in austin if you want to come
to the movie
you know hit me up maybe i can get you
in i don't i don't know i think they
probably want people to come watch the
premiere
then there's gonna be like a q a and
then i'm gonna be at the creek in the
cave
doing stand-up in austin so i want i
can't wait to see this like great austin
scene that they keep talking about the
comedy just you know so but i'll make
sure i don't do any asian jokes because
i don't want to get canceled
just kidding see context
uh that's probably the first thing i
will do and then do you see how that
would be funny though
like if i come out at the same place i
wish i was at the same place
this happened and then i could like me
making jokes about it
in that way would be funny because
of what happened that's all context
that's that's why
you can't just immediately judge someone
on what they say on stage
based off some clip somebody puts up you
need to know everything that happened
you know what's going on there this was
a live event you know what i mean so
anyways
nobody cares all right guys yeah this is
going to be a shorty but goodie
um thanks for listening thanks for
watching
uh thanks as always for doing what you
do because i i do appreciate you guys i
appreciate the support
i have like a my uh a small but mighty
fan base
and i do appreciate you guys and i i'm
keep pumping these out for you
you know because you know i do enjoy
doing it and
i appreciate the support and love so
keep subscribing keep following keep
doing all that stuff that you do
and i will see you next
week and it'll probably be i'll be doing
another episode on the road so i'll
probably be doing another episode
in austin next week so hopefully uh
maybe i'll find somebody out there i can
interview
and we'll see how it goes alright guys
take care
much love see you next week